let's go next - where do we want to go
next I mean there's just so so many so
many places to go let's try our caller
from the 973 area code
I believe 973 is Jersey which I would be
interested in hearing from who's there
today from 973 hi this is a jack
hey Jack where you calling from I'm
calling from North Jersey North Jersey
so how are things there with the virus
because that is an epicenter well
currently I'm at my office desk right
now I think I supported you about this
person in my building died we're doing
you have to come into work at your
temperature taken nurses are the doors
you have to do questionnaires make sure
you come and it's a state or federal
government job if I recall correctly
this is actually a DoD contractor so
it's not a state or federal but we work
with the federal government got it so my
question was regarding something that
you brought up a few weeks ago on your
show about the popularity of progressive
policies and how when they're asked in a
certain way people do not actually
approve of them or like them and I think
you could say that for most policies and
one of the reason why the right and
conservatives able to gain so much
popularity and win elections is because
they know how to properly phrase what
they want to get the American people to
stand behind them there was a great book
written in 2004 after the Bush
re-election called don't think of an
elephant by George lay cause of you
George about a very important book they
have very phenomenal I just read it
recently but I think what's important
for the left is that we need to work on
our framing and our messaging when it
comes to our policies because I do
believe they are very popular policies
but for example Medicare for all it has
to be presented to people in a way that
is digestible enough that it doesn't
sound like something that's radical
because
something that's crazy or impossible it
sounds something that's realistic
one of the ways I think that could be
done is when we think about people
arguing for more money going to the
military they say we need to strengthen
our country we need to have a strong
defense we need to protect Americans I
would argue you would use that same type
of language when saying we need a
universal healthcare system you know we
need our America we need Americans
healthy we need a straw we need a strong
working base we need strong citizens yes
health is strength to health is safety
etc right we are we are a strong country
when everyone has the ability to stay
healthy and we don't want to be I mean
it's almost like getting into this alpha
beta lame language that they used we
don't want to be beta by being weak and
letting people get the health health
care that they need you're sort of
getting into that idea of strength
versus weakness alpha versus beta
yeah and that's I believe how a lot of
people think yeah you know strong father
mindset I also want to interject one
more thing about the election November
yeah I am a libertarian socialist a
member of the DSA I volunteered for
Bernie I've donated for Bernie a phone
bank for Bernie and I'm going to be
voting for Joe Biden in November because
not voting for the person who's directly
running against Trump is helping him get
elected so I'm trying to get him eyes as
much damage as possible well listen I
think you know producer Pat is on the
line because he's tracking what we're
discussing here I think our first three
calls our Bernie guy is working for
Biden yang guy is voting for Biden
socialist is voting for Biden I mean
those those are our first three YouTube
titles I think from these three calls
all right well thank you very much David
you doing a great job great appreciate
it great to hear from you and stay safe
there in New Jersey